des vitrines parfaite qui vendent du
rêve avec chandail lunettes chaussures
dernier cri mais à quel prix arizona
muse mannequin internationale s'est
posée la question
[Musique]
les réponses trouvées ont eu l'effet
d'une douche froide car l'industrie de
la mode est la quatrième plus polluantes
sur la planète juste après le secteur
des énergies des transports et de
l'agroalimentaire à elle seule elle
produit 10% de toutes les émissions de
carbone la teinture des textiles et le
deuxième facteur de pollution de l'eau
dans le monde
la pause marching
une prise de conscience qui a poussé le
mannequin a fondé le angie bird un
organisme qui aide à promouvoir une
production moins aussi des fibres
utilisées dans la fabrication des
vêtements
en marge de la coop 26 elle et d'autres
acteurs du milieu de la mode ont
organisé un événement le but envoyait un
message aux décideurs qu'avec de la
volonté politique l'industrie peut
prendre un sérieux virage vert
il y à 50 émis par ni propriétaire d'une
marque de vêtements britannique s'est
lancé dans la production de vêtements
éco responsable la femme d'affaires a dû
travailler d'arrache-pied pour y arriver
au méchant
notre mission était de remonter la
chaîne d'approvisionnement jusqu aux
producteurs de la fibre mais c'était
vraiment compliqué nous avons dû
retourner à la source visiter chacune
des fermes et trouver nous-mêmes les
artisans qui transforme les faits
une démarche nécessaire pour s'assurer
que les fibres sont produites de façon
écologique et que les travailleurs sont
bien rémunérés et traités avec respect
la jeune femme a réussi à développer un
modèle exportable patrick grenthe fait
partie de ceux qui l'ont imité
community clos thing est une entreprise
locale et sociale qui produit des
vêtements de tous les jours et qui sont
durables équitable et abordable
la production locale lui permet de
divulguer la traçabilité de ces produits
en toute transparence
l'entreprise soutient trente et une
communauté britannique qui ont perdu
beaucoup d'emplois dans l'industrie du
textile avec la mondialisation
et pour vraiment répondre à la crise
climatique
patrick grenthe crois qu'il faut aussi
sérieusement réduire la consommation
nous ne faisons pas de collections
saisonnières les vêtements que nous
vendons aujourd'hui sont les mêmes
vêtements que nous vendrons l'an
prochain si vous créez une nouvelle
collection chaque saison vous ne fait
certainement pas partie de la solution
un message qu'envoie l'entrepreneur aux
grandes entreprises de marques
internationales
jusqu'ici les gens n'avaient pas
vraiment fait la connexion entre
l'industrie de la mode et la crise
climatique lance émis par nul il ya
encore très peu de soutien de la part du
gouvernement pour s'attaquer au problème
mais elle espère que ça changera des
géants de l'industrie comme les groupes
h&m nike adidas ont convenu cette
semaine de réduire de 50 % leurs
émissions de gaz à effet de serre d'ici
2030 et de tout faire pour limiter le
réchauffement à 1,5 degré mais la route
pour s'y rendre demandera de l'aide des
gouvernements et surtout des changements
de mentalité ici et les à céret
radio-canada à glasgow en ecosse